hi I'm patty Kim whether you're getting
ready to take on the morning or just
soaking in the shower at the end of a
long day the bathroom can be a retreat
from the world but it's also we're over
sixty percent that the water used
indoors gets consumed so if you like to
save water and money the bathroom's
great place to start let's take a look
and the biggest consumer of water in the
bathroom tada the toilet toilets made
before 1993 use up to eight gallons of
water per flush compared to only 1.6
gallons used by modern fixtures it's a
good idea to replace pre-1990 three
toilets if you can now if you're not
sure exactly how old your toilet is well
all you have to do is take the lid off
the tank and check out the underside
because usually there's a manufacturing
date stamped underneath even if you
can't replace your toilet right away you
can still save water using a one liter
plastic bottle just fill the bottle with
some pebbles or sand put the cap back on
and place it in your tank so it reduces
the water used with each flush believe
it or not plumbing leaks account for
about fourteen percent of the water used
in the average home so it's a good idea
to check your toilet for leaks here's
how put five to ten drops of food
coloring into the tank now put the lid
back on but don't flush wait about 15
minutes and check the toilet bowl if you
see any food coloring there's a leak
that's wasting water well a steaming hot
shower can certainly be relaxing but it
also happens to be the second biggest
consumer of water in the bathroom shower
heads made before 1992 can draw up to
five and a half gallons of water per
minute so check to see if your
showerhead is old or new simply turn the
shower on full-blast catch all the water
in the bucket and wait exactly two
minutes if the bucket is overflowing
then the shower head isn't a low flow
model new showerhead started around ten
dollars and installing one that draws
two and a half gal
or less per minute can save you fifty
percent with every shower now faucets
also have flow rates and if you take a
look at the screw on tip called the
aerator that will tell you exactly what
the flow rate of your faucet is if you
suspect that your faucets a water hog
all you have to do is unscrew the
aerator and take it to a hardware store
and match it to a new aerator that's the
same size the most efficient models have
flow rates of no higher than one gallon
per minute now to find the last water
saving device in your bathroom just look
in the mirror to save water all you have
to do is learn these few easy tricks and
you're on your way when you brush your
teeth turn the faucet off and use a
glass of water to rinse remember to put
trash in the wastebasket instead of
flushing it away skip the bubble bath
and take a shower instead taking a bath
can use up to seven times more water
than a short shower with a few simple
changes right here in the bathroom you
can keep plenty of water and money from
going straight down the drain thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time to
find out how green your bathroom is
click on the link below to take the quiz